Happy.
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in surah muz chapter number 73
verses number five 6 7 and 8.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala after
commanding the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam to recite the Quran
in melody, to recite the Quran at a
pace
that is neither too slow to change the
meaning of the the Quran nor too fast to
where the mind cannot keep up with the
compl
with the contemplation of the verses
being recited.
Allah Subhanahu Waaala then says
after commanding him to stand in prayer,
stand in prayer for the night, the
duration of the night, half of it or a
little less or a little more and recite
the Quran at a pace. He then says
subhanahu wa ta'ala giving us the wisdom
behind this command. Standing at night,
why night? Why not daytime? What's the
difference? What is the difference
between the night and the day? He says,
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu waala says and recite
the Quran at a pace. Then he says indeed
we are going to send down upon you a
very grave and very heavy word.
He says indeed the prayer and the rising
of the night.
It is most
likely for the heart to be in line with
the tongue when a person is praying at
night. The heart be in line with the
tongue. We'll discuss that in a
moment inshallah.
He says indeed in the day
In the daytime you have many things to
tend to.
However, at night it is more likely for
your tongue and your mind and heart to
be in line. He says, "And remember the
name of your Lord
and cut yourself off to him." To him.
So this statement
I want to ask a question here and this
is not rhetorical. I actually want an
answer and that is that when we deal
with words, the way people speak,
we have two types. We can ga categorize
all words, all statements into two
general categories.
What are those general categories?
Number one,
that which is obvious.
And number two, that which is implied.
Okay.
So what does that mean? We can we can
categorize all words into.
So that which is understood from the
general context and that which is
blatant and clear.
So what do I mean by this? If I say for
instance,
this man is a lion.
This man is a lion. From that statement
there,
are you deducing? Do you understand from
that that I'm speaking about a human
being or a real physical lion?
Huh? It's a human being, right?
Now, this isn't the obvious. This is
implied.
This isn't obvious.
Obvious would mean that you don't have
to look for other cues in the sentence
and context to understand what's being
said.
You just have to
you just you just hear it and
immediately understand it and everyone
would understand it. No two people would
disagree in its meaning.
Or we could also say there is that which
is
that which is literal and that which is
metaphorical. Let's go with that
translation.
Literal and metaphorical. Okay. Okay.
So, literal, if I were to say the word
lion, literal is a is an animal.
Correct?
Now, if I were to say lion and use it to
describe a human being, what do we
understand from this? That this man is
what?
[Arabic recitation]
the things that we associate with lying.
If I say the word snake,
right?
Snake. Snake is a is a literal animal.
It's a reptile. Right? If I say that man
is a snake or that man is a reptile,
what do we understand from this?
[Arabic recitation]
smiles just before he eats you. Right?
Those are the things we associate with
that animal.
The literal meaning is an animal.
The metaphorical meaning is what what's
understood from the context. Okay. What
why are we talking about this? This is
very important for us going forward in
understanding any verse of the Quran.
Now being that we understand we all
agree that words are potentially literal
or metaphorical,
right?
Which one is the essence of words?
Meaning
which one is the default position of
words? Is the default that I understand
everything as metaphorical
or is the detail that everything is
literal unless
it is metaphorical? Which one of those?
Do you understand the question? Like
what is the default in the way that
people speak?
Literal meaning, right? The literal
because metaphorical
it has conditions
and anything that needs a condition.
Okay, this is this is not beyond us all
understanding. I wouldn't take you
somewhere I didn't think you could go.
Just stay with me.
The essence of words is that all speech
is literal unless
it is metaphorical, not the other way
around. Okay?
We have literal things we say in
English. We have metaphorical things we
say in English. Right? If I say to you,
this is heavy and I'm speaking about a
box. What am I talk? What am I? What do
I mean by heavy? That it's physically
heavy. So that's literal, right? But
what about if the box is this big
and it literally only weighs an ounce? I
say this box is heavy. What does that
mean?
Serious, important, fragile,
grave. Isn't that what we understand?
So what tell what what made us think
that this is metaphorical and is not
literal because literally is not heavy.
Now literal is the essence of words. We
know this. Why? If I came running around
the corner,
eyes big, scared, clearly terrified,
running from something and you say,
"Whoa, whoa, what's going on? Where are
you running?" I say a lion is chasing
me. Does your mind go to an animal or
does your mind first go to a very brave
man?
[Arabic recitation]
That's because the default is literal.
Metaphorical is the exception in words.
Right? This goes for everything in the
Quran.
We have to have a we have to have a
ground rule. We have to have a
foundation that we understand words by.
We either take everything metaphorical
and literal is the exception or we take
everything literal and metaphorical is
the exception.
When we go to understanding the Quran,
the Sunnah
and all sane human beings
say that literal is the default.
Metaphorical is the exception.
Right? Sometimes both are intended.
Right? Sometimes both are intended. If I
pick up my son that's growing up, right,
and I say, "Oh, he's heavy. This could
mean both, right? Means that he's
literally heavy and at the same time
he's very what? Very important. Correct?
So there's no problem with both meanings
being accepted
together. Sometimes it's only the
literal that's mention that's
understood. Sometimes it's only the
metaphorical that's understood and
sometimes both can be understood. Okay,
if we understand that
then we understand that the default with
respect to the words of Allah is that
they are literal in meaning
and the exception
is metaphorical.
So for instance, if we go to and this is
by the way, this is an issue which is
not agreed upon amongst the majority of
Jews and Christians.
A huge portion of Christianity and Jew
Judaism believe that the Bible or the
Torah or what have you is metaphorical.
It's not literal in its meaning. So when
they say for instance Adam and Eve were
in a paradise and they were told do not
eat from a particular tree that this is
this didn't actually happen because they
say well we had we had evolution you
know people started as bacteria and
turned into fish and grew legs and came
outside and stood up and and turned into
human beings. So there was no beginning
where it was Adam
created by Allah with his hands. Adam
alis being created from clay and how
being made from his rib. This is all a
metaphor. Do we understand that?
That is not the way that we understand
the Quran.
This is what we refer to as alia.
Albinia is a group
that came out around the second century
after Hijra who were deeply influenced
by rhetoric of the Greeks and Romans and
Persians.
And as a result they understood it the
opposite that everything is metaphorical
and
literal is the exception.
So when Allah says that he hears doesn't
mean that he really hears. This is what
they say.
Hearing is something specific to human
beings. We hear the creation hears but
Allah does not hear. So he is all
hearing but he doesn't hear. This is
exactly how they say he is allseeing but
doesn't see.
He is all knowledgeable but doesn't have
knowledge. He loves but he doesn't have
love.
He is merciful but has no mercy. And
this is exactly how they say it.
[Arabic recitation]
were very influenced by them
and subsequent groups that came along
later.
However, this Baltia
looks at everything as being
metaphorical unless
there's evidence to state that it is
that it is literal. So they'll look at
something and this is this is
heresy. This is heterox. This is zen is
what we call this. Why?
Because this means that all of the
commands of the Quran and sunnah are are
circumstantial.
Allah says stay away from alcohol. Well,
it doesn't mean that alcohol is haram.
It just means that stay away from
anything that will make you behave as if
you are drunk. But alcohol itself is not
haram. This is their words, not mine.
This is what led them to this is because
everything is metaphorical. Right? And
they later began to say there is no
prayer five times a day. Prayer is the
awakenedness of the heart. Right? There
is no fasting. Fasting is refraining
from things that you are addicted to
things this. And so
because it's a slippery slope when you
say Allah rose above his throne, they
say there's no real throne. It's not a
throne. It just means that Allah assumed
kingship, right? Well, that's a problem
because if the throne is not literal and
there is no real tangible physical
throne,
then the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said that paradise's ceiling is is what?
Huh? the throne of Allah.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said if
you ask Allah for paradise ask him for
the highest point of feros
because its ceiling its sky is the
throne of Allah.
But then if we say the throne of Allah
is just a metaphor
then that means that paradise is also
what is a metaphor. And if paradise is a
metaphor, then that means that the seven
heavens, which paradise exists above, is
also a metaphor.
And if the seven heavens are a metaphor,
then the earths are a metaphor. Correct?
And they continued down this slippery
slope until they said, "There is no
difference between the creator and the
creation. They are the same thing."
Why is that? Because just right now when
I say the word unicorn, what just popped
into your head? Everyone,
huh? A horse with a horn, right? And
wings. Does a Does a unicorn actually
exist? No. So this creation is actually
all just as we have thoughts in our
mind. This creation is all just a
thought in the mind of the creator. This
is what we call pantheism.
Hinduism is based on pantheism that
there is no difference between the
creator and the creation.
Where did all this start? What was the
you know sometimes there's a thread
that if there's a thread here you say
shikh let me get that thread you the
whole arm falls off right that's what
that thread was this topic of
literal and metaphorical
which one is default you see how that
little question how much is based on it
so when we hear that there was a man
named Adam and he was created from clay
and Allah created him with his hands and
he put a soul into him and he told the
angels to prostrate themselves. Is all
of this literal or is this just
metaphorical?
This is absolutely literal.
Absolutely literal. When our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
that Allah created the heavens and the
earth in six days and then and then rose
above the throne. And then inki he tells
us that
men
wasallam the first one to be for the to
be brought from his grave on the day of
judgment will be the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He said, "I
will ascend from my grave and find misam
holding to one of the a part of the
throne of Allah." Holding to one of the
legs on the throne of Allah.
Now if we say the throne is metaphorical
then what's that mean? That means MS is
metaphorical too. Correct? That means
the grave is metaphorical too. Right?
That means that everything is a
metaphor. Nothing is literal. Everything
is just a metaphor.
This is so important
that strictly
everything is literal in the Quran and
Sunnah unless
it is clearly
evidenced
and clearly bolstered by the Quran and
Sunnah that this is an exception to the
rule. It's not meant literally. It is
rather meant what? Metaphorically.
This is such an important such an
important principle of understanding the
Quran.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
stand, it means literally stand.
Unless something in the context tells us
that what was meant by that was
metaphorical. Do you know the story of
the two companion the the two groups of
companions when the prophet sallallam
said
you remember this narration do not pray
hurry go to do not pray unless you are
in
there's a narration
now that could mean
do not pray assur unless you are
physically
Or it could mean hurry. Hurry so fast
that you wouldn't miss and you could
catch it in.
Those are the two meanings, right? Which
one is literal?
Which one is literal?
Huh? Praying physically there. That is
literal, right? And what is
metaphorical?
hurry up. Correct. Now, the companions
didn't agree.
Some of them said, "No, we have been
commanded to pray in so we will pray
in."
And they continued and they missed time
and they prayed it in.
And the other said, "No, what's
important is we what's what's meant what
he meant was for us to hurry, but it's
time for and if we don't pray now, we
will miss salah in its proper time."
Now, some of them prayed on time and
some of them prayed at Ben.
When the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam was later told about this.
Which one did he point out as being
correct?
he pointed out as being what he
intended was haste, hurry. But he did
not blame either of them.
Why didn't he blame either of them?
because they have a they have an excuse
in understanding the literal because the
default is literal.
Right? That is what is meant by this
narration which many of us have heard.
They were both correct in doing what
they thought was right. But the truth is
one. It's not two. There can't yes and
no can't both be correct simultaneously
at the same time. Right? It can't be
black and white at the same exact time.
It can't be day and nighttime at the
same exact time. It has to be one. These
are two conflicting mutually exclusive
things.
Everybody understand that? Now, Sheh
Ali, why did you take us around this
block here? Well, first of all, we are
going to be getting into a lot of that
in the future in the Quran because when
we hear Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
describe himself, his descriptions are
literal or metaphorical.
They are literal
as befitting for his majesty and we will
discuss that inshallah.
But they are literal. They are not
metaphorical.
If if the names and attributes of Allah
are not literal, then what else could
possibly be literal? That is the
strongest most self-evident truth in all
of existence. The names and attributes
of Allah. How could anything be literal
if the names and attributes of Allah are
not literal? They are literal, but they
also carry a metaphorical meaning with
them. Because as we said metaphor and
literal they don't necessarily clash.
Now where did all this come from?
Because Allah says
indeed we are going to send down upon
you a very heavy, very grave, very lofty
word.
Heavy here means literally heavy or
heavy here means important.
Which one is it?
Important important
literal
said while I was sitting next to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam his knee
was resting on my thigh. This is
inahkari.
and revelation came down upon him and I
felt a weight to his body. I thought
that my thigh was going to break under
the weight of revelation
in a mus Ahmed the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam was on his camel in
Mecca when surah Mah was revealed
and when surah Maha was revealed his
camel started to buckle under the weight
of revelation
and he had to get off of his camel to
save its life under the weight of the
revelation.
That means that this verse is literally
these words when they were revealed had
a literal weight and an influence on the
physical world.
But it's also metaphorical because they
are very heavy in their meaning. They
are very grave words,
right?
And so when you go now go home and open
something like
and read what the Sahabah or the or the
scholars of say about this verse. Some
of them will say literally heavy and
others will say no very important. Which
one is correct? Both of them. Both of
them are correct. As long as a literal
meaning can carry an appropriate
metaphorical meaning, the verse means
both and we only resort to one or the
other when it is impossible to harmonize
the two. This is how we unlock and start
to understand the Quran.
I know it's very easy to sit back and
listen to stories and we do that right
how many narrations and stories and do
we hear here a lot but this is what
knowledge is this is how knowledge works
now when you hear someone say Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala doesn't have a face
we say
The Quran says that, right? You say,
"No, that's metaphorical."
We understand now how the scholars of
Islam arrive at the conclusions that
they arrive at. We will, this is a very
important lesson. This is probably one
of the most important lessons we've ever
had since I've been here.
And we will always refer back to this
lesson and this principle going forward
in the Quran because this topic comes up
almost every single verse that we read.
[Silence]
and